[Music]
the thirteenth year I guess Disney
really had a thing about turning kids
and the merpeople didn't they well kind
of like Little Mermaid - this one is
kind of as least interesting as that one
was not to say it's awful it's just not
really anything which is a shame because
again I don't think this is that bad of
premise her mermaid is swimming with her
young baby but a man sees her in a boat
afraid for her son's safety she drops
him off and tries to distract the man
the boat only to have a couple one of
them played by Dave Coulier pick him up
take him to the police and when nobody
claims him they decide to adopt him
sunburned a mother surprisingly just
kind of stays away for 13 years until
suddenly the boy named Cody starts to
notice certain changes he's swimming
faster he's growing gills he has
electricity oh and he can stick to walls
um yeah and vampires Sparkle his parents
don't know what to make of it the doctor
just says it's puberty yeah second
opinion much only his nerdy best friend
can figure out what it is he's turning
into a merman how does he know because
his father is the one that saw his
mother years ago Oh small world first of
the story is just him coming to grips
with his powers trying to find his real
mother while also keeping his girlfriend
while not embarrassing himself while
also trying to make the swim team and
the championships
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah it's about as
generic as it gets
there's a ton of things that don't make
sense in this movie like I said before
the mother staying away for 13 years
come on she couldn't flop on to the
beach and get someone's attention or
something just destroyed the mystery if
your freaking kid hell she distracts the
man in the boat by showing off what she
is and he's like oh my god I gotta prove
mermaids are real and everything what
she showed off to that guy why couldn't
she show off to other people keep it a
secret why is it even a secret why don't
you use your electric powers that you
suddenly have yeah I guess they kind of
make a connection to electric eels but
that doesn't explain why they can stick
to walls everyone is just a little off
to like the swim team makes fun of him
because he always comes in second
comes in second that's impressive even
the girlfriend for his birthday just
gives a picture of herself that's
strangely narcissistic and then she just
closes her eyes waiting for a kiss
everything this movie is just a little
off there's another scene where his
hands are sticky and he's shaking him
off and then the mother just starts
doing it too and then the father comes
in and starts doing it but what's even
going on here this is some quirky
strange this is just strange strange
even Cody's performance is a little
strange I mean it's not laughably bad
I'm he's not over-the-top or too goofy
but maybe that's kind of the problem too
he doesn't really stand out he's just
kind of boring
he's the every kid to a fault you can't
really imagine yourself in his shoes
because he doesn't have much of a
reaction I don't know if he was written
that way or directed that way but it
just doesn't come across as anything the
only thing I really took out of this
movie strangely enough is the guy that
sees the mermaid originally you may
recognize him from a few Sam Raimi
movies like a simple plan and he always
kind of plays this southern redneck
bumpkin he always does this part really
well to a point where it's actually
legitimately dramatic the part where
he's talking to his son about what he
believes and he can help it and is he
crazy looking for other people crazier
than him it's actually kind of touching
I always got a perk up every time he's
in a movie it's always interesting but
aside from that when Dave Coulier is
your next most credible actor you kind
of know you're not in a good spot like I
said I can't say this movie is terrible
it wasn't awful watching it it's just
kind of like watching nothing it's
really a shame not only is this an
interesting idea I mean the ocean
underwater fish life I mean it's
interesting but it's also unique that
took an idea that's usually meant for
girls you know mermaids are usually
girls and gave it a little bit of a spin
by making it a boy
you think these little touches would
help it stand out but it just kind of
gets lost in the mix I don't know if it
was just an uninteresting script or if
there wasn't time to direct it in an
interesting way or shoot it in an
interesting way but it's mostly just
forgettable aside from a few dedicated
fans it's unlikely this one's gonna stay
afloat for very long
you
[Music]